[Musique]
alcatel savez on va parler d'un
smartphone dans le milieu de gamme non à
des derniers smartphones d'alcatel de
cette année 2018 un smartphone milieu de
gamme
je vous le dis tout de suite c'est pas
le smartphone le plus haut de gamme
c'est pas là dessus qu'on va y
rechercher les performances très
clairement non alors ce que je vous
propose
je vais vous montrer le smartphone je
vous dire à qui il est destiné et qu'est
ce que vous allez pouvoir faire avec
pourquoi acheter l'alcatel 5 v est ce
qu'il est intéressant d'en faire un
petit tour complet du côté de la photo
du côté des performances et que finale
ce sera à vous de me dire en commentaire
ce que vous en pensez et lui mais avant
j'ai une bonne nouvelle parce que c'est
elle qui a t'elle 5,20 pas celui là
un qui n'aura pas été ouverts tout beau
tout neuf vous est offert pour
participer c'est hyper simple vous avez
un lien en bas dans la description vous
cliquez et vous allez voir pour gagner
c'est très très simple le vole à alcatel
5 v où j'aime bien le design tout ça pas
mal
le module photo est plutôt bien bon vous
avez grand capteur d'empreintes
digitales là la marque
la certification européenne vous avez un
effet coque incurvée 3ds et vitrifié bon
c'est pas mal ce efficace il prend les
traces de doigts ça ça c'est un grand
classique aussi on va pas trop trop lui
en vouloir point positif vous avez la
prise jack sur le dessus sans le côté
grands standards bouton on/off bouton de
volume en bas du micro usb un haut
parleur mono qui situent juste là là
vous avez une micro sim et une carte
micro sd revenir a ajouté on peut le
smartphone en lui-même se déverrouille
très facilement avec le capteur
d'empreintes digitales
il marche bien on tourne sur un android
oreo 8.1
on laissera médiathèque 6762 3 giga de
ram 32 gigas de stockage qu'on peut
étendre jusqu'à 128 gia très clairement
ce n'est pas là-dessus qu'on va voir le
max de performance par contre le point
positif est le point fort ce smartphone
c'est son grand écran d'une diagonale de
6,2 pouces un ratio de 19 neuvième
résolution hd plus c'est pas du full hd
1500 par 720 pixels un écran qui
occupent 88% de la face avant l'idée de
ce smartphone dans le milieu de gamme
c'est le multimédia pouvoir profiter
d'un écran qui même c'est pas du full hd
est quand même relativement sympa pour
visionner
des vidéos pour aller sur les réseaux
sociaux regardez les vidéos sur youtube
netflix que vous voulez pour aller sur
instagram
ça fait franchement la faire il est
plutôt pas mal dans l'expérience de
visionnage ça va bien quand même plutôt
très bien alors je vous le dis même si
on n'est pas là dessus sur un écran full
hd
ça fait franchement le job la qualité
est quand même relativement la leçon est
assez médium pas trop trop lui en
vouloir
ça vienne là là on a un seul
haut-parleur ici le saura smartphone
directement pas trop trop chères mais
moins dans sa catégorie il fait la paire
il ya un point qui fâche mans bien ces
sacs grosse batterie de 4000
milliampères heure là franchement vous
êtes tranquille vous pouvez le garder
une journée et demie sans aucun problème
ça va bien évidemment toujours dépendre
de vos usages si vous êtes très gourmand
très gourmande forcément autorise un
petit peu moi ça
par contre pour un petit peu négatif là
dessus quand on n'a pas de recharge
rapide c'est le temps de recharge
complète qui est assez long on est un
petit peu moins de trois heures 2h48 si
je vous dis pas de bêtises donc voilà il
faut prendre son mal en patience lorsque
vous allez leur charge et dites vous
bien que vous allez devoir le laisser un
petit moment sur la prise autant de
prévoir de recharger la nuit parce que
la journée si vous voulez de recharge
est repartie rapidement sera pas trop ça
à côté de ça l'autonomie
franchement est cool ça c'est un point
positif j'arrive même à faire tourner
pdg de sueur et gaieté graphique est pas
complètement complètement folle mais
malgré tout ça va quand même pas trop
mal c'est assez fluide ça tourne
et ça franchement c'est hyper cool je
vois pas de blague j'ai absolument pas
de problème ça marche donc ça c'est
aussi un point très positif
qui peut le plus peut le moins des jeux
comme un sac lui trop tombe très très
très très très bien dessus ça en termes
de père franchement c'est cool on vous
voyez vous pouvez faire quelques jeux un
peu cool vous pouvez faire au rouge
c'est n'importe quoi pouvait faire
tourner quelques jeux pour regarder des
vidéos présentent du multimédia ça
franchement c'est cool
maintenant il ya un autre poste
important sur ce smartphone assez la
partie photo vidéo la partie photo avec
un double capteur 12 mégapixels + 2
mégapixels le 12 mégapixels ouvre à f
2.2 indice que le 2 méga pixels venir en
renfort pour le mode portrait ouvre à f
2.4 et l avance vous avez une caméra de
8 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.8 pouvait
filmer en full hd à 30 images par
seconde et l avant en 720p à 30 images
par seconde
autant dire que l'on va pas trop trop
lui en demander mais pour faire des
photos pour partager sur les réseaux
sociaux
franchement ça fera bien
vous avez ici plusieurs modes
automatiques panoramique time lapse
social trace lumineuse portrait micro
vidéo google health bon mode portrait
vous connaissez c'est un grand standard
100 marches franchement plutôt bien
times la liste panoramix lou pastre
rapidement trace lumineuse
ça va vous aurez beaucoup plus longtemps
aux objectifs et ramassez pas mal de
petites phrases ont pour faire la
création c'est assez intéressant mais ça
c'est du gadget micro vidéo vous pouvez
tourner des vidéos pour le format des
réseaux sociaux en soit en 15 secondes
soit en une minute
bon ça c'est aussi plutôt pas mal et
voyez le résultat au final marche bien
là on est sur le mode portrait de notre
portrait je trouve qu'il a vraiment bien
des tours et au niveau du doigt et il a
bien reconnu là entre les doigts c'est
franchement pas mal c'est pas non plus
parfait mais franchement pour voir qu'on
est que sur un média thèque 6762 ça
marche franchement très très très bien
notre portrait de base sont celles assez
simple ça marche très bien
ça c'est la caméra de saïfi bon voulait
pas j'ai vraiment une sale tronche là
dessus mais sinon ce que ça marche quand
même dans l'absolu super bien on a du
détail sur les photos alors c'est pas la
plus grande qualité quand pouvoir
retrouver les couleurs sont assez bien
rendue c'est pas sûr saturé et du point
de détail ça fonctionne quand même
plutôt pas mal
je vous dis une fois de plus ce n'est
pas sur l'appareil photo le plus dingue
du moment mais pour voir qu'on est sur
un smartphone milieu de gamme
le boulot est vraiment bien fait que
j'en profite quand même pour vous
montrer la boîte plutôt bien fait j'aime
bien les couleurs ça c'est sympa
alors hop je vais vous montrer ce qu'il
ya dedans y'a pas là on a une petite
coque de protection une petite coque
transparente à l'intérieur on allait
câble de recharge en micro usb
forcément on a une paire d'écouteurs
fatalement on a de quoi adapter la
taille des écouteurs à votre oreille
le bloc charge et bien évidemment des
informations sur votre smartphone qu'on
l'ait très clairement patient smartphone
le plus fou de l'année un bref sur une
grosse révolution volée sur un produit
qui est franchement honnête et à 229
euros
il fait le franchement le job il se
positionne da l'entrée du milieu de
gamme pouvoir pourquoi pas dans le haut
de gamme de notre gamme
à vous de voir dites moi ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
smartphones d'alcatel moi j'en ai eues
mais il y a longtemps et à l'époque
c'était pas des smartphones celui là je
trouve bien je trouve qu'il a un
bon compromis au niveau de l'affichage
la photo est pas mal
si vous cherchez de la performance à
l'état pur c'est pas là dessus qu'il
faut aller mais si vous voulez un bon
smartphone dans le milieu de gamme
vous serez pas déçus que je trouve qu
alcatel 5v et bien et avec un écran 6,2
pouces même si c'est du hd plus il est
cool
il fonctionne bien à vous de me dire ce
que vous en pensez directement en bas en
commentaire et puis je vous dis c'est
alcatel 5 verra pas celui là un modèle
tout neuf tout beau tout chaud et a
gagné vous avez le lien en bas dans la
description
je vous invite à consulter ma playlist
pour découvrir tous les smartphones du
moment
et puis d'ici là premiers soins que vous
soyez sages je demande et vous très
bientôt
tiens